his parents decided not
to give him the hrh title but he will
actually
technically be a prince of the united
kingdom
when prince charles takes the throne the
point is whether or not archie
will choose to use it harry and megan
will have no say if archie decides he
wants to reclaim the royal life
but that won't be tilly's 18. for now
archie is
the prince of montecito with his very
own playground at the family's new
massive 9 bedroom
19 bathroom mansion i have been told
that megan and harry
were pleasantly surprised that it took
the press as long as it did
to cotton on to where they'd eventually
chosen to make their home
this is their forever home this is where
they want to be for many years to come
the duchess has been busy she sat down
with feminist icon gloria steinem in
santa barbara to talk about voting
people forget how hard women like you
and so many others before you fought for
us to just
be where we are right now but megan was
a bit upstaged by her two dogs
honey wants to be on camera
she and harry recently made a surprise
appearance to hand out baby supplies in
la
and they've been secretly pitching tv
shows to hollywood studios
there is a lot of speculation that
they're pitching tv programs about
civil rights about feminism about black
lives matter
you